panel for something it's a saddle of
lamb basically a sort of Rolls Royce cut
perfectly shaped and it's suits stuffing
to an absolute tea for the stuffing
finely chop an onion garlic nice thin
slices oil in onions and garlic in just
salt and pepper make sure the stuffing
is goofy season so it helps to season
the inside of the lamb now we've got a
color on those onions
we're throwing some pine nuts that helps
to give a bit of a texture is where
starts getting really exciting spinach
in and just lay the spinach over the
pilots it looks like a lot of spinach
that's gonna condense and disappear
almost instantly so much more flavours
things when you slow to it as opposed to
steaming you're boiling you gas off look
at that now to bring that together no
eggs no bread crumbs crumbled feta over
the spinach feta cheese adds a beauty
salty sharp and creamy flavor what this
does it brings that stuffing together
now open up the lamb keep there's little
Phyllis to the side that's the channel
that we want to stuffed I wanna just
open that up a little bit there salt and
pepper lightly and before we put our
stuffing in we're season it with sooner
sumac is a wonderful lemony spice that
goes brilliantly with lamb and you can
get it in most big supermarkets it sort
of cuts through that thick rich
sweetness of the lamb open up that lamb
there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day ahead then let the stuffing
cool down it's inevitable when you start
rolling it and tying it something to
squeeze out so load up the ends take
these beauties these little fill it and
to support that stuffing and sort of
increase a beautiful tunnel and then
from there over there and bring that
towards you and then roll like I said so
my stuff is going to come out now but
tight first off around the side and
don't worry about some flash which is
not just tight one in the middle you can
get butcher string from your local
butcher or cookware shops I got two ties
go to tie it just forces all that
stuffing out of the lamb when it's in
the oven
nice now what you see on the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned now you think normally
that just goes in the oven like that
that's how my mum would do it but get
you tray onto the gas oil in get it
really nicely colored none of the
stuffing is coming out of the sides
really important look at that color
beautiful does kickstart a roasting
process gas off into the oven cook for
45 to 55 minutes depending on how pink
you want your lamb
lick the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin or stop
it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices next I'm making a
simple but sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tail the cucumber
peel it cut the cucumber into three and
just core take it out away it's just
sort of watery see Liam it spoils the
flavor slice cucumber cucumber in really
nice way of making a cheap and cheerful
cucumber look glamorous we're gonna
dress that cucumber with a nice fresh
yogurt with tablespoons next it's a
fresh mint dressing touch a salt touch a
pepper and then pomegranate molasses
that just swings it up finish that with
lemon mix that up
laughs its rested carefully take off the
string and then just gently pull in
there straight edge edge knife that's
going to cut through that crispy foul on
the outside instantly I tied it
purposely so I can get my portion
control from the lines hold it nice and
firmly look at your line where the
string was and look this one is gonna be
amazing
lay and down just in those two slices
there
it proves that stuffing meets this for
special occasions because that is a
saddle of lamb at his absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast thinly slice fresh fennel and
scatter over the toasted flatbread
then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan next drain your pasta and
combine with a sardine chilli and garlic
mixture add leaves a fresh oregano